usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido diagnosticada con cáncer de
ovario este vídeo le ayudará a entender
cómo manejarlo
y los ovarios son dos glándulas que
están en la pelvis de la mujer estos
producen hormonas y óvulos para la
reproducción
el cáncer de ovario es una enfermedad en
la cual las células cancerosas crecen
sin control en sus ovarios el
tratamiento para el cáncer de ovario
puede eliminar o destruir el cáncer
después del tratamiento es muy
importante tener un plan de cuidado con
seguimiento esto incluye ir a todas las
citas de seguimiento su médico querré
asegurarse de que el cáncer no ha
reaparecido además de comprobar si hay
problemas de salud resultantes del
tratamiento es probable que necesite ver
a su médico con frecuencia después de su
tratamiento pregunte acerca de qué tipo
de programación puede esperar si usted
está tomando algún medicamento continúe
tomándolo según lo prescrito por su
médico
tomé notas de cualquier efecto
secundario e infórmese lo a su médico
si se ha sometido a cirugía de ovario u
otros tratamientos siga las
instrucciones que se le han
proporcionado
también puede ser necesario hacer
algunos de los siguientes cambios
saludables a su estilo de vida no fume y
limite la cantidad de alcohol que bebe
ambas actividades pueden aumentar su
riesgo de cáncer
como una dieta saludable con más frutas
vegetales y granos enteros
una dieta saludable puede reducir el
riesgo de que el cáncer regrese
manténgase físicamente activo el
ejercicio y las actividades diarias
pueden hacer que se sienta mejor es
importante hablar con su médico antes de
comenzar un plan de ejercicios o hacer
cambios de estilo de vida
tenga en cuenta que algunos tratamientos
contra el cáncer pueden hacer que se
sienta muy cansado
pregúntele a su médico qué puede hacer
para sentirse menos cansado
y saber que tiene cáncer puede ser
abrumador es posible que tenga
preocupaciones sobre su afección y cómo
afecta a su familia sus tratamientos y
estancias en el hospital gastos médicos
y su trabajo
afortunadamente hay maneras de lidiar
con esto hablé con su equipo de atención
médica ellos pueden ayudarle a encontrar
el soporte que sea adecuado para usted
las siguientes fuentes de apoyo pueden
ayudarle a abordar sus preocupaciones
trabajadores sociales
líderes religiosos
consejeros
y grupos de apoyo
hablé con su médico si tiene alguna
pregunta sobre su plan de tratamiento
medicamentos o cambios de estilo de vida
que le ayuden a manejar el cáncer de
ovario